Last in our chart making journey
is going to be line charts and
line graphs are really effective
at showing trends over time.
We need to have a continuous variable
on our x-axis, x-axis being the
one on the bottom and then we're
able to look at another number and
see how it tracks over time. A
lot of times this gives us really
great insight into things like
seasonality, are you selling a lot more
products in your Q4 because of
the holiday season? And then you
expect to see kind of a drop-off
for Q1 the following year. A lot of
these are going to show us trends
over time. Are we generally trending
up? Are we generally trending down?
That lets us, as all graphs do,
identify potential problems or
identify successes or identify patterns
so that way we can plan for
the future. So line graphs are
especially great at understanding
those things as they relate over time.